well I just design a new kitchen for
myself and that is my ideal kitchen I
live in a nineteenth-century house and I
took my absolute favorite room in the
house and left it exactly the way it is
and plopped a kitchen right down in the
center so the the ideal kitchen to me is
the center of the house so wherever you
like to spend the time the most the
ideal kitchen should be there whether
that's in the middle of your living room
or out on your deck or whatever it is
and then and then you don't need too
much I mean I am somebody who
professionally cooks at home and I have
four burners you know I I don't I don't
think that having you know a hundred
burners in your kitchen makes you a
great cook
so I think a really beautiful
environment where you like to be and
that has everything that you need apart
part of the beauty of cooking at home is
that it's yours and you do things your
way
so I'm somebody who can live with one
knife so some people need 15 knives just
as you walk into some people's house and
they have all kinds of little things
everywhere and you walk into some
people's house and they've one book
sitting on a shelf and that's it it's a
personal self-expression so you know
sort of the message on HIGH about how to
stock the perfect kitchen or how to
create the perfect environment in your
home in any way is totally wrong you
need to you need to search your soul
figure out who you are if you're a
minimalist have one knife if you're a
maximalist have a hundred whatever you
want to do is your perfect kitchen